la solution pour les couturiers
absolument raisons dont le fait qu'on
doit pas les mettre sur le même plan
mais le problème des pitreries de 30
c'est que ça envahi l'espace médiatique
et que donc et ça ne peut pas faire
autrement que vous avez après donc il
fait cest witkin et n'importe quoi qui
refait on n'aurait jamais pensé je suis
surveillé
ddd et des absurdités de sites
extrémistes d'un autre pays des choses
comme ça comment voulez vous que ça m'a
envahi ce pas l'espace nautique et du
coup comment vous les boucles d'une part
ça ne provoque pas première et fait
moins d espace pour les discussions
sérieuses sur la gravité du problème et
deuxièmement en effet des effets
d'équivalence on a un fouet un autre fou
alors qu'on a un dictateur fou et on a
un président démocrate pitre c'est qu'il
n'est pas la même chose mais ça provoque
ses effets catastrophiques donc c'est
quand même très très mauvais les trucs
de trop